THE SENATE HOUSING COMMITTEE.
WE WILL CALL THE ROLL TO
ESTABLISH FORM. THIRTY WIENER
PRESIDENT WIENER PRESENT MORALE
BATES. BATES PRESENT CAMARO
CAMARO PRESENT DRAWS A. DRAW
THE PRESIDENT MCGUIRE.
PRESIDENT MORE LUCK FOR LIKE
PRESENT ROUGH ROUGH PRESENT
SKINNER NUMBER YOUR NUMBER
PRESENT BECAUSE HE. OKAY WE DO
HAVE A QUORUM AND WANT TO START
BY GIVING WE ARE VERY SPECIAL
RECOGNITION BECAUSE WE A
MIRACLE HAS HAPPENED HERE IN
THE SENATE HOUSING COMMITTEE
THAT CENTER MCGUIRE IS HERE
WHEN THE HEARING STARTS. THAT
HAS NEVER HAPPENED BEFORE
HOWEVER. AND SO HE WILL NOT BE
WINNING THE MIKE MCGUIRE OR
WORDS TODAY'S HEARING WAS FOR
YOUR TO THE PERSON ARRIVES.
LOTS OF. THE WELCOME CENTER
MCGUIRE. NEXT YEAR. I THINK
THERE ARE A FEW OF THOSE
FLOATING AROUND MAKING. SO. SO
TODAY CAN BE IN THIS SITE
HEARING WHICH SHOULD BE A BRIEF
HEARING BECAUSE WE HAVE A
SENATE BILL BACK ON CURRENTS SB
ONE EIGHTY TWO BY CENTER
JACKSON THIS IS A TWENTY NINE
TEN G. CANADA TO CONSIDER
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE
ASSEMBLY THE OPTIONS FOR THE
COMMITTEE TODAY OR TO HOLD THE
BILL IN COMMITTEE TO RETURN THE
BILL TO THE SENATE FLOOR WITH
RECOMMENDATION OF THE AMENDMENT
SPEAKING CURRENT AND RETURN THE
BILL TO THE FLOOR WITH THE
RECOMMENDED AND THAT THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IT'S NOT BE
CONCURRED IN ORDER TO RETURN
THE BILL TO THE SENATE FLOOR
WITHOUT A RECOMMENDATION. AND
WITH THAT. I'D LIKE TO TURN. TO
JACK. I THANK YOU MISTER AND
THE I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COME BEFORE YOU
TO PRESENT THIS BILL INTO
PLANNING BILL THAT ESTABLISHES
STATEWIDE PROTECTIVE STANDARDS
FOR COMMUNITIES IN FIRE RISK
AREAS AS YOU MENTIONED THE BILL
IS HERE BECAUSE THERE WERE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE
ASSEMBLY OF THE HOUSING ASPECT
OF THOSE AMENDMENTS FURTHER
ELABORATED THE FRAMEWORK FOR
HOW RINA ALLOCATION AND THE
RAIN ALLOCATION PROCESS SHOULD
CONSIDER THE FIRE RISK. OF
THERE IS SOME CONCERN ABOUT
THOSE COMMANDMENTS AND AS SUCH
I WOULD LIKE TO SUGGEST THAT
THE COMMITTEE CONSIDER MOVING
THE BILL TO THE SENATE FLOOR SO
THAT IT MAY BE RETURNED TO THE
ASSEMBLY FOR FURTHER ACTION
WITH THE UNDERSTANDING THAT A
WORKING GROUP WILL BE CONVENE
TO WITH RELEVANT PARTIES AND
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING BUT NOT
NECESSARILY LIMITED TO THOSE
FROM THIS COMMITTEE. AND THE
SENATE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU ARE
SENATOR AND FIRST OF ALL I
WANTED SHOWS THANK YOU FOR
CARRYING THIS BILL TO ADDRESS
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
ISSUES FACING OUR STATE. AROUND
WILD FIRES AND- HOW WE SHOULD
APPROACH HOUSING AND WILD FIRES
AND HELD A SORT OF INTERACT
WITH EACH OTHER THIS IS A HARD
AND DIFFICULT ISSUE YOU PUT A
LOT OF WORK INTO THIS. AND I AM
1100% CONFIDENT THAT THIS BILL
WILL BE AMENDED IN JANUARY AND
WE WILL ALL BE SUPPORTING AND
GETTING IT SIGNED AN ACTED
QUICKLY. AND YOUR LIPS TO GOD'S
EARS THANK. SO THE GOVERNOR'S
HEROES YES MORE PARTICULARLY SO
AGAIN I WANT TO PUBLICLY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP IN THIS
AREA WITH THAT. WE WILL THERE'S
A- LOT. OF IS THERE ANY
SUPPORT. OR OPPOSITION SEEING
NONE BRING ABOUT THE COMMITTEE
WITH EMOTION. BY SENATOR ROTH
OF THE MOTION WOULD BE. THE
MOTION WOULD BE ABOUT THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS BE TAKEN UP
FOR CONSIDERATION IN OTHER
WORDS ON THE POSSIBLE FOR. SO
WITH THAT MOTION BY SENATOR
ROTH ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
COLLEAGUES YES CENTER LIKE
HEALTHY I WOULD JUST ADD THAT I
THINK THAT IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT
WE DO SOMETHING IN THIS AREA
HI. I UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN
THAT THE CHAIRMAN HAS THE THIS
IS THE DESIRABILITY OF DOING
PLANNING ESPECIALLY IN THESE
HIGH HAZARDOUS AREAS IS WE
WAITED TOO LONG WE SHOULD'VE
BEEN DOING THIS TEN YEARS AGO
OR FIFTEEN YEARS AGO AND N. AS
WE ENTER ANOTHER FIRE SEASON.
I'M CONCERNED THAT A LOT OF
LOCALITIES ARE GONNA BE MAKING
A LOT OF BAD DECISIONS BECAUSE
WE HAVE BEEN RUNG THE BELL THAT
YOU CAN'T DO THIS ANY LONGER SO
I APPLAUD THE EFFORTS OF BOTH
THE CHAIR AND THE AUTHOR AND I
WISH THAT. WE WERE UP FULLY
COOKED BUT I'M I'M SUPPORTING
EVERYBODY'S EFFORTS HERE THANK
YOU SARAH KELSEY AND OF COURSE
THE BILL CLINTON GOING TO
AFFECT BEFORE JANUARY FIRST I
BELIEVE THAT IF WE'RE ABLE TO
PUT IN HOPEFULLY URGENCY CLAUSE
IN IN JANUARY. PUSHES THROUGH
IT WILL BE A VERY VERY BRIEF TO
LIE BUT I FULLY AGREE WITH YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COULD COME AS IT IS GOING TO
TAKE LIMITED THANK YOU TO BOTH
THE OTHER IN THE CHAIR FOR
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE IT'S
CRITICAL. IT IS A REALLY
SUBSTANTIAL BILL IN PRECIADO
THE SENATORS LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ONE I ALSO WANTED MOMENT TO
KNOWLEDGE THE CHAIR OF FOR HIS
WILLINGNESS TO WORK THIS
THROUGH A AND B. COLLABORATIVE
ON THIS IN JUST ONE AT EIGHT
KNOWLEDGE HIS HARD WORK. AS
WELL ON ALL ISSUES OF HOUSING.
AND. SENATOR JACKSON'S. MOTIONS
AT THIS ONLY MOMENTS BIG TAKEN
UP FOR CONSIDERATION SENATOR
WIENER. HI WIENER AYE MORRELL.
BATES BATES AYE CAMARO. CAMARO
I DRAWS. RATHER AYE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE MOORLACH. FOR A LOT
I ROUGH. ROUGH AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE NUMBER NUMBER I
CASKEY. OKAY I AND ZERO COMING
YOU KNOW. TO KEEP IT OPEN. OKAY
OKAY THEM VOTERS TEND TO NOT
PAYING THE MOTION IS PASSED AND
WE ARE ADJOURNED AND BECAUSE IF
I MAY SAYS NO NGUYEN IT'S
POSSIBLE WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
ANOTHER HEARING OF THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE LATER TODAY ON A
SEPARATE BILL IF IT COMES BACK
FROM. THE ASSEMBLY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR